[Music]  about where advertisers they hold the  cattle that's so interesting  boy oh boy oh boy little comfort anymore  okay okay you're a grown man and you  should really close your mouth when you  eat it you know what I don't care what  happened did that she is just very  sensitive and I don't think that you  should so like I don't know you know  what you know it you're right I'm sorry  [Music]  so it's worth exploring the the beauty  of and we have no we have noticed I can  we find the phone that's ringing guys  the moms love us so let's just keep that  up the wires can break the wires can  break you can actually take that outside  [Music]  hey did you eat this  [Music]  [Music]  Vall brave  [Music]  yeah I believe imagining now  [Music]